the war drums keep beating louder
as russia continues its relentless build
up surrounding ukraine on three sides he
continues to do the things
that you would expect one to do if if
one was planning on a major military
action monday ukraine's president
defiantly seized on the claims made by
western intelligence about an impending
invasion
we are told february 16th will be the
date of attack said vladimir zelinski as
he called for solidarity we will make
that a day of national unity
sitting with vladimir putin in moscow
russia's foreign minister insisted
diplomatic options are far from
exhausted
nervous european allies still share the
view that a russian attack could come at
any moment
canada is withdrawing its military
trainers from ukraine the u.s is closing
its embassy in kiev moving the few
remaining diplomats to near the border
with poland president putin may well
decide to order an invasion and now has
the ability to do so
in short order in kiev local analysts
remain hopeful putin may not go all in
the access to
kiev doesn't look like to be a realistic
scenario without like a great losses
from russian side nato insists there is
still a path to peace though it's
looking narrower by the day
the best way for russia to demonstrate
its readiness to find a peaceful
solution is to de-escalate
and remove their forces which are now
threatening ukraine all the while
ukraine's future relationship with the
west hangs in the balance president
zielenski now suggests nato membership
may only be a dream for his country
a message perhaps meant to appease the
russian forces amassing at his border
jackson prosko global news washington